almost eight years of civil war hundreds
of thousands of lives lost millions of
people displaced but still President
Bashar al Assad stays in power a reality
that's not changing anytime soon with
Russia also gaining influence
according to Britain's top diplomat I
think you know the British long-standing
position is that we won't have lasting
peace in Syria with that regime but
regretfully we do think he's going to be
around for a while and that is you know
because of the support that he's had
from Russia and you know Russia may
think that it's gained a sphere of
influence what we would say to them is
yes and you've also gained a
responsibility and if you're going to be
involved in Syria then you need to make
sure that there really is peace in Syria
and that means making sure that
President Assad does not use chemical
weapons on his own people it's a new
public acknowledgment by the UK of the
situation in Syria
even though Jeremy Hunt is simply
stating the obvious Assad with his
Russian and Iranian backers is
strengthening his grip on power while an
internal uprising supported by Britain
and his allies is fading some countries
like the United Arab Emirates are
reopening their embassies in Damascus in
a show of confidence in the Syrian
president he's been able to consolidate
his position there'll be many people in
Syria who are bitterly disappointed that
that has been the outcome but if that is
the outcome then there are going to be
countries that want to reestablish
diplomatic ties his comments contrast
with those of David Cameron is prime
minister who talked of regime change
what we've seen in Syria are appalling
scenes of death and suffering because of
the use of chemical weapons by the Assad
regime and I don't believe we can let
that stand that means having a
government that's not terrorizing its
people and that is why as sad must go
that seems naive to hope for now a
parallel conflict in Syria against
Islamic state could also be nearing the
endgame after Donald Trump announced
last month he would quickly pull all US
forces out of the country though he then
signaled the exit would be slow
I changed the Foreign Secretary welcomed
warning the militants were far from
defeated what I would say is that the UK
assessment is that the war against daesh
is not over and so there is a need for a
continued Western presence in Syria and
Iraq well in both countries the war is
not over Jeremy Hunt has also focused on
what to do about suspected Isis
militants from the UK who are being
detained by Kurdish forces allied with
US troops in Syria particularly if the
US troops leave this includes two
alleged members of a group called The
Beatles that beheaded hostages that is
one of the issues that is going to have
to be resolved during the course of this
year we don't think it's something
that's gonna have to be resolved in the
next month or two months but the issue
of ISIL prisoners in Kurdish held errors
is something that has to be resolved as
part of a an orderly withdrawal could
you see them coming back to the UK the
British Isis prisoners well I wouldn't
to speculate on what the solution would
be but I would simply say that our
priority in this has always been one
very simple priority just make sure
these evil men see justice
one man unlikely to face justice for war
crimes is Assad who could succeed in
regaining complete control of Syria this
year
Deborah Haynes Sky News Singapore